over 50 men and women clad in red robes
kneel before an unholy altar they chant
and mutter indecipherable words
words of cruelty and madness of
obsession
and sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people
computer technicians teachers plumbers
construction workers accountants
this was before they fell under the
ungodly influence of a new ruler
the center of this makeshift place of
worship was once a normal school
gymnasium
but it's now the home of a huge statue
a humanoid being wreathed in tentacles
its head is more like a squid or
cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face while he's known to
the cultists as the tentacled god
the beast they worship is known to the
scp foundation as scp-2662
and he sits in the belly of one of their
expansive containment facilities
locked away from the world but not for
long
if his devoted followers have anything
to say about it
this is their god all powerful and
unchanging
and when it comes to springing him from
containment no tactic is too vile
or underhanded to get the job done their
mortal leader and high priest
a man in a purple robe calling himself
brother marsh
walks among their crouched forms he
whispers
instructions for the great day of
liberation that's soon to come
providing everyone plays their part it's
a plan months in the making
and one that if it goes off without a
hitch could free their monstrous god
into the world
they would strike at the very heart of
their enemy
the scp foundation when they least
expect it
and nothing shall stand in their way how
could they lose when they have a god on
their side
but why did all these normal people
become violent zealots for a squid-faced
deity
it all began with a dream to those who
experienced these dreams they felt more
like
prophecies premonitions of the glorious
horrors to come
a red sky billions dead and billions
more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled god
holding dominion over all at first it
just seemed like a strange nightmare
the ones who experienced it woke up
shaken and afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't
every night the nightmare would return
they'd see the images
the red sky the dead and enslaved
the tentacled god and after a while it
would come to them
even when they weren't asleep eventually
happening whenever they closed their
eyes
little by little this scene stopped
looking so hideous
and started to look glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future
they started to realize that they wanted
him to rule over the universe
and to experience the honor of serving
him many of them abandoned their homes
and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd gone
insane in their eyes they were safer
than they'd ever been
they finally had purpose they were
working in service of something far
greater than themselves the influence of
the tentacled god drew them closer to
one another
they would meet in secret exchanging
information from the prophecies their
ruler sent to them in their dreams
they worship together building altars
and idols to congregate around
they perform dark blood rituals
involving human
and animal sacrifice it was when brother
marsh
the anointed one arrived to guide them
towards their true mission that things
kicked into high gear just three months
prior
brother marsh had been an office drone
working in data entry for a large
insurance company
before the tentacled god invaded his
thoughts with a
simple message free me and the new world
i create
shall be your playground since then he
devoted himself completely to the cause
quitting his job and maxing out his
credit cards to help
fund his new life's purpose infiltrating
the scp foundation
and releasing his inhuman ruler from its
imprisonment
that was the single goal he united the
cultist under
freedom for the tentacled god and at
long last
they had all the pieces in place to
strike they'd finally gathered the
necessary intel to subvert the will of
the most powerful secret organization on
earth
even the strongest institution is made
of people
and people are weak unlike the almighty
tentacled god
people could be broken the people in
question were kelly thompson
sydney levitt jordan broche dr juan
gutierrez
and jillian larson dr juan gutierrez was
a researcher with level three clearance
on the site where the tentacled god was
being contained
sydney levitt and jordan broche were
both security officers charged with
verifying personnel clearance on site
kelly thompson was a member of site
administration with research
authorization powers
and jillian larson was a research
assistant who often collaborated with dr
gutierrez
these five were the key to getting
access to scp-26
and bringing their plan to fruition
normally personnel dossiers on people
working for the foundation were highly
confidential
but the devotees of the tentacled god
had their ways
they had a number of computer experts in
their ranks more than capable of hacking
in and pulling some basic information
off of foundation servers without being
detected
for the other information they needed
they turned to some good old-fashioned
torture
which is often the most effective method
when you need some quick results
of course while the colts grip on sanity
may have been a little tenuous
they weren't stupid while gathering
their intel they also made sure to find
out what exactly they were up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell
and guarded by on-site task force tau 9
better known as the belligerent
bodyguards these aren't lazy donut
chomping mall cops
these are a heavily trained heavily
armed fighting force
though the cultists had one thing that
these foundation soldiers
didn't the element of surprise
for everything to go off perfectly
brother marsha's plans would have to be
executed within a single day
and they were already on the clock tau9
had been charged with tracking down
any new scp-2662 cults and dismantling
them
and brother marsh knew that it was only
a matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down
and did the same to them if they wanted
any chance of freeing the tentacled god
then they'd need to strike quickly and
with overwhelming force
the scp-2662 worshipers were able to
secure the addresses of the five key
foundation personnel
and station members outside each of them
including one who could realistically
imitate
each they waited for night to fall and
broke into each of their homes as they
slept
what followed was a sequence of ruthless
and efficient murders done
in the cause of freeing their god dr
gutierrez was shot in the head while he
slept
sidney levitt and jordan broche were
both stabbed to death before either even
realized what was happening
thompson who'd gotten up to use the
bathroom went down in the hail of
machine gun fire
jillian larson had seen that mask
figures were breaking into her home and
attempted to flee
but was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway
it was a strange irony that people whose
day jobs entailed working with some of
the most dangerous and nightmarish
anomalies imaginable
were murdered in their homes by nothing
more than
regular humans so far brother marsha's
plan
had gone perfectly with all five key
personnel murdered within a two minute
period
next the selected doppelgangers stole
clothes from their victim's closets
and were handed the correct forge
documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their journeys to the site where the
tentacled god was being contained
while the rest of the cult armed
themselves in preparation for their own
part in the plan nobody at the
foundation
seemed to notice anything amiss when the
five arrived on site
when you work for the scp foundation
more mental energy is devoted to
following the rules that keep you alive
then two memorizing the faces of all
your co-workers
and each one slipped neatly into
position disappearing
into the familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled god
would be another thing
entirely that's where the rest of the
cult would come into play
heavily armed with whatever firearms
they could get their hands on
the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother marsh included
would attack the containment site head
on
in the ensuing chaos the five cultists
who had already infiltrated the site
could take advantage of the distraction
and break into the containment chamber
it was perfect
they launched their attack from the
outside and from within
when brother marsh declared that the
time was right the assault
began a legion of gun wielding cultists
seemed to spring out of nowhere
and started shooting up the warehouse
that was a front for the containment
site
the site quickly mobilized guards and
task force members to take on the sudden
threat
and just as brother marsh had
anticipated the site director called on
the majority of town nine to help repel
the violent cultists from their
perimeter
tao9 obeyed leaving three task force
members behind a guard scp-2662's
containment chamber
they expected to be guarding the cell
from rampaging religious zealots seeking
an audience with their god
what they didn't expect was a group of
five foundation employees
walking right up to them and opening
fire
killing two tau nine members and taking
the third as hostage
while the war was being waged outside
the infiltrators had found the tentacle
god's containment cell in the
low-risk humanoid war their hostage
insisted that using him wouldn't give
them any leverage
the rest of his team would neutralize
the whole group him included
if that's what it took to stop them the
infiltrators explained that using him as
leverage was never their intention
he wasn't a hostage at all he was
a sacrifice the cultists of the
tentacled god detonated explosives
creating a hole in the wall and finally
giving them access to their deity
they climbed through and gazed upon him
in awe
there stood scp-2662
twice as tall as a regular man with 10
huge tentacles emerging from its back
in their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators
what they certainly didn't expect was to
see
the tentacled god hunched over a
computer screen
still god's work in mysterious ways so
they stuck to the plan and began
chanting they pulled out a sacrificial
dagger and began sacrificing their
captured tau-9 member
it was at this point that scp-2662
turned and saw what they were doing with
a look of pure horror
he rose up from his computer his
headphones getting caught as he did so
he told them to go away that he didn't
want them here
and that the murdering people in his
bedroom like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting
the cultists became even more confused
why wasn't their god accepting their
offerings
what were they doing wrong they tried
more chanting and painting arcane
symbols on the floor in blood
but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them
in a tone more fitting for a teenage boy
than a lovecraftian god
to just leave him alone so he could play
his video games
this was seriously not cool
the cultists were baffled they told the
tentacled god that they were there to
free him
he replied that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself
into the foundation in the first place
before the cultist infiltrators could
get another word in
the remaining members of town nine
stormed into the containment cell and
gunned them down
with surgical precision the war outside
was already over
brother marsh and the rest of the
cultists were all killed in the fire
fight tau9 didn't look the least bit
surprised upon entering 2662's cell
this was a common occurrence
unfortunately they had to deal with an
attempted cult invasion every few months
because scp-2662's main anomalous
ability
is inspiring violent cults who
relentlessly track down and worship it
with arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously
and definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the scp foundation
who keeps him amused with video games
and reading material
while fending off the deranged cults who
try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled god
just one of many cults who'd broken into
2662's containment cell
the remaining tau 9 members apologized
to the tentacled creature for the
disturbance
allowing him to return to his gaming
they assured him that it'd probably be
at least a few more months before
something like this happened again
scp-2662 cell was repaired
and the foundation returned to its task
of seeking out would-be cult
emancipators
because for the scp foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment
but what's being kept out now go check
out
scp-096 the shy guy and scp-087 the
stairwell
for more strange and surprising stories
from the scp
foundation